so this past week a bunch of voiceover
actors came out and stepped down from
their roles if they were playing black
or biracial roles so Jenny slay on the
show big mouth actually voices a
biracial character and she stepped down
saying that it should be played by a
black actress instead Nick Kroll also
came out in support of this and then the
guy who voices what's his name's
Cleveland from Family Guy also stepped
down oh wow I don't agree with any of it
I think you're an actor and you should
be allowed to play anybody you want I
think a black person should be able to
play a white person in a cartoon kind of
black person with a white person can a
black person play an Asian person can an
Asian person play a white person what
are we [ __ ] talking about if you're
an actor and you're good for the the
actual part then it should be colorblind
it should be about it should be about
talent and humor and the best person for
the role and I don't think color should
play a role in it at all but now since
you're playing identity politics on that
side yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
but this is Hollywood this is the
horseshit that Hollywood does because
they feel helpless and they want to be
part of a movement and they do this with
everything and I happen to know Jenny
slate and I know Nick Kroll and I like
those guys a lot I respect them and
Jenny's really telling it and a great
person and so I'm not I'm not
criticizing her necessarily I don't
agree with her choice
and I don't even agree with it as a
gesture but that's me or pinellia make
different people gonna be upset if like
okay and they rewrite Cleveland as a
white guy and then that white guy still
plays the voice what about a woman who
plays a child can a woman play a child
what are we talking about here what
about a a large person who plays a dwarf
is that allowed or do you need a dwarf
what are you what are you talking about
this is this this is the kind of
horseshit that doesn't make the world
less racist it doesn't make that that
doesn't do any good it doesn't have any
impact it's just an empty popular
gesture you know I was just thinking
about her now the one of one of my
biggest break one of the biggest things
I've done was a commercial for Rango
right for what for Rango oh yeah the
woodwork
Johnny javi and I did a very
country-western white accent and you
know that was my biggest Beano thing
I'm Korean so how would that look that's
a sweet doesn't look bad well how about
the guys cause I'm an actor the guy who
does I blew on Simpsons just like 40
voices on yeah yeah you have to step
down as their boo it's like it's
ridiculous I I just think that I just
think there were actors and I don't
think it should be allowed to do that I
don't think it's helping what's not
helping in the direction that I think
everybody wants so Brennan you know yes
that's so so George Floyd Rashard Brooks
these two guys were shot you know I mean
one guy was killed terribly executed
Rashard Brooks more controversial but
but can if if these and I've said this
before I mean if you really care if
these corporations and Hollywood who
take responsibility if you guys actually
really care about it's like on Father's
Day weekend in Chicago Brennan a hundred
black people were shot at though
primarily from other black people
well well five kids were killed eight
kids were shot
so that's on one weekend in Chicago so
if you if you care and if you're serious
where were you what are you doing about
that and where is your outrage and why
is CNN not talking about that oh I see
and why is nobody talking about that but
you're talking about that one guy and
you're not talking about a hundred
people shot in Chicago we can go through
this little list is it so but it's--but
kid makes no sense mainstream media's
you know they suck at the enemy they
don't tell the truth
what lukacovic do yeah how has no one
report on they're not responsible people
I don't I don't think they're good
people I think they're bad people I
think they're political activists look I
don't know who they're for I don't know
what they're doing and I and I and I and
it's why the CNN's ratings suck so badly
this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]